[Musique]
le champignon est un produit noble dont
le goût se distingue par sa subtilité
qu'ils soient sauvages ou de culture on
doit d'abord le nettoyer moi je
préconise vraiment l'eau pour enlever le
maximum saleté le chef pascal aff on
n'hésite pas à les rincer à l'eau malgré
la croyance populaire les quelques
secondes dans les bras le temps de la
terre de se déposer au fond du bol et là
il ya aucune raison pour que les
champignons et dépérit absorber de l'eau
c'est vraiment le juste milieu un peu à
la limite on voit même rafraîchir et
voilà les éponges
alors champignons de paris et
champignons café crimes unit m'amuse
isation là on va l'utiliser dans une
poêle et la poêle et reste la méthode la
plus commune pour cuire les champignons
elle permet d'en fortifier le goût
nouveau juste commencer par annuel qui
tolère bien la haute température arraché
de cameline et pépins de raisin ou
encore l'huile de canola
à cette étape-ci de la cuisson on
n'utilise pas de beurre parce qu'il
résiste mal à la haute température
on s'assoit quand une bonne voire une
très très chaude
l'idée c'est de faire à haute
température - l'autre exactement parce
que ça fond on voit que les champignons
beaucoup verte ici donc on les laisse
travailler sans trop non plus les bouger
dans une belle création
non je vais exercer et là on ajoute un
petit peu de crème pour lier faut
beaucoup donc sa compagne n'importe quoi
poissons les viandes
le pleurote kingston se distingue par sa
forme et sa texture parce qu'on va faire
on va y aller vraiment les tranches
relativement et pince ça s'entend même
un cas c est un champignon qui est ce
que j'aime faire j'aime bien pris dessus
on voit on a une belle coloration une
belle coloration déjà je peux déjà
considéré retourner et comme une viande
le champion va lui laisser un petit
temps de repos à valdes est en dessous
donc ce que je fais après ça je vais les
écouter les éponger servi en salade
ils seront pleinement mises en valeur
[Musique]
on peut utiliser plusieurs variétés de
champignons dans une même poêle et nous
avons le hainaut qui champignons
asiatiques
c'est un champion qui est très très
fragile tout ce qu'on a à faire c'est
simple on coupe comme celle ci et voilà
et après si on peut soit les services
entiers comme ça où le hyaric comme un
fromage en lanières comme sopi les
séparer plus haute
comment ça se travaille un peu comme les
nokia on reçoit les couper ou encore une
fois les détacher si on veut et ça fait
une belle portion le goût disponible en
une seule bouchée
ça c'est un de vos champions préférés le
cheetah qui laisse pas exactement qui a
un goût particulier ou pas je dirais un
peu noisette
mais l'ong au toucher la forêt dans ce
champignon et moi ce que je fais ce que
je veux dire la tige qui est très très
dur on les garde
évidemment pour n'oublions pas nos
soupes pour nous comme on garde tous
fiables les sites acquis quand ils sont
plus petits on peut regarder tel quel
sinon on va juste les 6 lits
pour sa recette de pâtes forestière le
chef nous recommande une portion
d'environ 50 g de champignons par
personne l'europe si on dépose d'abord
les pleurotes qui prennent plus tant à
cuire puis les cheats à quai et
finalement les nuls king
on voit les textures du champion
s'éteindre ça c'est ça c'est encore là
je vais exercer la bière jus de pomme
est-ce qu'il faut pas beaucoup de sens
mais c'est suis un pur non feinte
[Musique]
ces chantres we wanted qui peut être
coriace prudence lorsque je suis si
j'enlève le bout comme celui-ci avec
l'économe
on fait juste gratté et retiré la
première couche de la tige en fait ça
enlève un petit peu l'amertume d'un
champignon et puis pour le couple ont pu
aller soit au couteau ou au puis allez
simplement avec nos mains pour les
déchirer on voit la structure c'est
super fragile délicat
la chanterelle avec sa couleur vive est
tout indiquée pour accompagner cette
pièce de boeuf
si on récapitule pascal les grands
principes de questions de champignons
sont sont une bonne très très chaude
huile neutre payer champignons qui sont
la vie à sécher puis on les fait rôtir
des glaces et assaisonner et aux mains
rouges et ses bons essais bon voilà
[Musique]
oh